Il se positionne hyper
facilement. Vous l'ouvrez, vous le mettez,
vous le lâchez. Il se pose juste là. Je le ne trouve pas trop
intrusif. Au début c'est assez bizarre ...
Aujourd'hui je vous parle d'une start up,
de produits innovants et de produits
destinés aux personnes sourdes et
malentendantes. Si vous me
suivez
vous savez que j'aime bien parler de
start up. Pas tout le temps,
de temps en temps. J'ai souvent parlé de
start-up liées à l'écosystème français :
la French Tech, Business France.
Aujourd'hui je vous emmène en Corée du Sud.
Je vous parle d'une start-up coréenne
très intéressante qui a créé un
tour de cou pour les
personnes sourdes et malentendantes.
C'est un sujet je trouve vraiment très
intéressant. Quand
on m'a proposé de vous en parler j'ai
tout de suite dit oui. Il s'agit de ce tour
de cou. Je vais vous expliquer à
quoi il sert. Si vous êtes sourd ou
malentendant, est-ce que vous connaissez
ce produit ? Vous me direz à la fin en
commentaire si c'est quelque chose que
vous pourriez avoir et si vous
connaissez une solution équivalente.
La marque s'appelle UFirst. Le produit : Nuguna.
C'est un tour de cou.
Il a un micro de
chaque côté. En fonction du son qu'il va capter
capter à droite ou à gauche
il va vibrer d'un côté ou l'autre d'une
certaine manière en fonction des bruits
qu'il va entendre. C'est vraiment très
intéressant parce que ça permet de
capter la provenance d'un son.
Un exemple : la sonnette va retentir.
La porte est de ce côté là. Une vibration va se faire sentir.
Le porteur va être alerté en direction du bruit.
Ca permet de localiser la source du bruit.  C'est
un système qui va vous alerter. Par
exemple le micro-ondes est en marche.
La cuisine est par là bas.
Vous lisez ou faites
autre chose. Le micro-ondes sonne
"ding" et le casque vous alerte
en direction du bruit. Vous
savez que le micro-ondes fonctionnait,
ça vous indique que vous
pouvez récupérer votre plat.
Il existe de nombreuses
fonctionnalités.
C'est un tour de cou qui est très
malin, très intelligent. Je vais vous montrer
comment il fonctionne d'un point de vue
matériel.
Vous le posez autour de votre cou.
Cette partie est flexible. Sur le côté on retrouve une LED
qui vous aide à connaître le
niveau de batterie, pour le synchroniser ...
Ici se trouve le bouton pour l'allumer et l'éteindre.
Ici des boutons
pour adapter la sensibilité.
Il peut réagir uniquement aux bruits très forts,
il ne réagira pas aux sons moins forts.
Tandis que si vous baissez la
sensibilité, il va
réagir à de petits bruits. ici vous le
rechargez en micro USB. Ici vous
réglez l'intensité de la vibration.
Il peut vibrer plus ou moins fort. Ca va déjà dépendre de la
sensibilité personnelle du porteur du
tour de cou. Ca va dépendre de vos habits
si vous avez des vêtements qui sont un peu
plus épais, notamment en hiver,
ou alors si vous êtes en tee shirt que
vous l'avez directement sur la
peau, vous n'avez pas vouloir les mêmes
sensations. Vous pouvez le régler
directement ici. Il a un mode
pause. Par exemple s'il y a beaucoup de
bruits extérieurs. Vous pouvez le mettre
en pause.
Vous laissez appuyé pendant 2 secondes,
il va se mettre en pause.
Néanmoins il n'est pas
éteint. Pour le
réactiver vous appuyez pendant 2
secondes il se réactive.
Il se positionne très facilement.
Vous l'écartez et vous le mettez facilement autour du cou.
Je ne le trouve pas trop
intrusif. Au début c'est assez bizarre.
D'un autre côté  je n'en ai pas le besoin
donc c'est étrange pour moi.
Ca me parait bizarre
mais je suis allé me balader dans
la rue, j'ai fait différents essais. Au bout d'un moment vous ne le sentez plus.
Je ne suis ni sourd ni malentendant
donc je ne vais pas en ressentir le besoin
ni le bénéfice de l'avoir sur soi
et de capter des provenances des sons.
Néanmoins au bout d'un moment
on s'y habitue et les
vibrations vous gênent pas.
Lorsque vous le portez pour la première fois, vous avez ce truc qui va vibrer,
pas constamment mais dès qu'il capte un
bruit il va vibrer, ça peut paraître un peu
bizarre. Mais on s'y habitue très
rapidement.
Il a son application que vous pouvez retrouver sur iOS et Android.
Sur iOS il sera disponible à partir
d'avril 2019.
Par contre sur Android il existe pour quasiment toutes les versions
d'Android. L'app s'appelle Nuguna.
Votre niveau de batterie s'affiche.
Il ne se décharge pas très vite. Les technologies à l'intérieur ne sont pas
énergivores : un micro de chaque
côté, une LED,
des vibreurs. Il communique en
Bluetooth.
Il y a une partie pour la gestion de l'alarme. Vous allez pouvoir régler une
alarme pour le matin. Vous dormez avec votre tour de cou.
Vous programmez le jour et l'heure de votre réveil matinal.
Vous calibrez la durée de la vibration,
vous calibrez l'intensité, vous enregistrez un nom à l'alarme et c'est tout.
Lorsque quelqu'un va vous vous appeler
sur votre téléphone vous allez
pouvoir régler à l'intensité de la
vibration et le nombre de vibrations. Vous pouvez également régler
le mode de vibration (continu ou alterné).
Vous pouvez faire la même chose pour les SMS.
Vous pouvez facilement identifier le type de message ou
d'appels, de notification que vous allez
recevoir. Il ne va pas vibrer de la même manière.
Vous allez pouvoir créer des
alertes pour la prise de médicaments.
Par exemple j'ai créé une
alerte mes antihistaminiques.
Avec les beaux
jours qui arrivent les
allergies sont de retour.
Je programme la prise du Kestin
à 3 H11.
Le soir ce serait mieux, à 9H c'est parfait.
Je régle mes paramètres, je sauvegarde.
Je peux créer autant d'alertes que je veux.
Vous pouvez l'utiliser pour des médicaments mais également pour autre choses.
Vous créez des rappels dont vous
pouvez l'utiliser pour tout ce que
vous voulez.
Il existe de nombreux cas d'usage. Si vous avez des animaux à la maison et
il aboie, vous voulez savoir où ils sont.
Dans tous vos déplacements même à l'extérieur.
Si vous voulez traverser et que quelqu'un klaxonne. Vous identifiez la provenance du son.
C'est vraiment intéressant. Ca aide à percevoir les dangers,
à connaître la provenance d'un son, à
pouvoir identifier un appel, un SMS, si
quelqu'un sonne à votre porte, si le micro-ondes sonne ...
Vous pouvez identifier la position d'un son. Ca
vous sert de réveil. C'est une solution
polyvalente avec de nombreux cas d'usages insoupçonnés.
C'est un outil qui se développe.
Vous pouvez le commander depuis la France.
Il coûtait $298. S'il vous intéresse je
vous ai mis le lien dans la
description.
Vous pouvez le trouver à $278 pour le moment.
Actuellement les frais de
livraison pour la France coûtent $77.
Le produit vient de Corée et il a du voyage à faire jusqu'à chez vous.
Mais pour le service
rendu
je pense que c'est vraiment intéressant.
Il existe dans plusieurs couleurs : blanc,
or, noir et gris. Je le trouve super intéressant.
C'est une vidéo que je fais avec mes
potes du Café du Geek. Vous pouvez
retrouver leur article complet via un lien dans la
description ainsi vous aurez pleins
d'informations complémentaires.
Voilà pour ce
produit
le Nuguna. La société s'appelle UFirst.
Il nous vient tout droit de Corée.
C'est vraiment une solution qui est
intéressante. Dites-moi en
commentaire ce que vous en pensez.
Est-ce que vous êtes une personne
malentendante ou sourdes ?
Vous noterez qu'il y a la transcription sur cette vidéo. Dites-moi ce que vous en pensez.
Est-ce que cette solution vous parait intéressante ?
Est-ce que vous pensez qu'elle a une vraie valeur ajoutée
pour les personnes sourdes et
malentendantes ? Je trouve le concept très
intéressant mais c'est compliqué pour moi de vous dire exactement ce qu'il en est
parce que je ne suis pas confronté
à cette problématique donc c'est très
compliqué de pouvoir vous donner le
retour exact mais en tout cas je trouve
que c'est vraiment un outil intéressant
et je me pose une question,
je compte sur vous pour m'aider à y
répondre. Est-ce que vous
connaissez des solutions alternatives,
des solutions similaires qui existeraient
sur le marché ?
Et est-ce que celles-ci vous semblerez, si
c'est le cas, plus
intéressante ? Je vous invite à
me dire tout ça en bas en commentaire.
C'est une vidéo un peu à part mais ça valait le coup.
Je vous donne donc rendez-vous dès
demain on sera au MWC à Barcelone
pour découvrir toutes les nouveautés de
l'univers de la téléphonie mobile :
smartphone et bien plus encore ... Vous
allez voir ça va être hyper cool.
Je vous réserve pleins de surprises.
Je vous embrasse, à demain. Ciao.